hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
sieht vorstellung für die minecraft
version 1.5 so wir gehen hier wieder den
einzelspieler erstellt eine neue welt
ihn in die ferne welt gehen kreativ und
das hier ist der zieht - 6712 580 39 und
was uns in diesem sieht erwartet das
seht ihr genau jetzt also wir sind erst
mal einen ganz normalen dschungel
bionorica lightning fehler war es
allerdings wie das wir hier hinfliegen
müssen wir fliegen also die ganze zeit
an diesen dschungel hier ist ein kleiner
krater wohl dort wieder ein furz
aufgefahren wir fliegen hier so ein
bisschen an junge einfach so ein
bisschen vorbei hier direkt an der
grenze grenzen mich ein derby um an den
dschungel hinten an ihn heran ich weiß
es nicht und ihr seht bei den
koordinaten wir müssen zu den
koordinaten - 300 c a oder 320 und z
sollte 230 sein
und dann müssen wir es jetzt jeden
moment schon sehen und zwar haben wir
hier eine pyramide und dort hinten was
gerade noch verdecktes haben werden in
pc village das werde ich euch gleich mal
zeigen wir gehen allerdings erstmal die
pyramide rein und zwar ist das
eigentlich jetzt schon relativ seltenen
pyramide zu finden und ein npc village
in der wüste auch hier ist beides direkt
aneinander allerdings ist das ja
eigentlich normal für den sieg
vorstellung das also was kommt doch hier
sind richtig richtig geile sachen mehr
drin und zwar haben wir mehrere
diamanten in den kisten hier auch
nochmal und was wir gleich im pc village
finden das werde ich euch gleich auch
noch mal zeigen ich kann es einfach
nicht verkneifen ich kann es mir nicht
verkneifen
ihnen muss es immer machen doch es ist
so schön
auch herrlich und was wir auch noch im
mpc village haben das werde ich euch
jetzt mal zeigen denn da haben wir auch
diese nimmt man das mine open house
keine ahnung
jedenfalls habe ich auch so ein paar
geile sachen drin weil hier ist die
kiste drin und wir haben auf jeden fall
sehr sehr sehr sehr geile sachen drin in
diesem in diesem in diesem end pc will
schon in dieser pyramide dingsbums als
ich mir die welt in der 1.5 punkt was
war da jetzt irgend so ein neues
snapshot oder irgendwie sowas erstellt
habe hatte ich sogar 315 diamanten und
3m areals ich weiß nicht wo die alle
geblieben sind
wegen wie es hier gerade ein bisschen
weniger drin ist allerdings auch egal
wir haben auf jeden fall schon mal zwei
rüstungsteile wir haben noch mehr sachen
und zwar 24 knochen woraus uns auf jeden
fall eine menge knochen mehr machen
können und dann dieses feld da hin zum
beispiel die samen können zwei diamanten
können uns natürlich auch ein tolles ja
mancher direkt aus basteln 13 obsidian
direkt passend für portal ab die hölle
unterhalt wie gesagt rüstungsteile
fressen und so weiter also ist auf jeden
fall sehr sehr geil zudem auch noch eine
menge felder hier wo wir uns einfach
dran bauen können wo wir ein bisschen
graben können und allgemein sich das
terrain hier in der umgebung sehr sehr
offen und zwar wieder hinten einerseits
den dschungel mit bestimmt noch ein paar
dschungel tempeln da drin wir haben hier
eine riesige schnee blieb das ist so
weitläufig schnell geflogen da findet
ihr gar das ende
wir haben hier halt eine komplette wüste
allerdings finde ich das ganz gut dass
die wüste direkt neben so ein bisserl
das hier ist grundsätzlich mein
lieblingsbier und zwar einfach diese
diese weiten sag ich mal wo wir einfach
gras haben und halt einfach ein bisschen
eine freie fläche ist born sehr oft
einfach kühe oder schweine oder so und
es sieht auf ihre oder eine kuh unter
dem link wollen wir die marke freiem
einen starken bild mit freunden kannst
du raus kommt ja toll wollte die
befreien alleinunfall gut finde ich auf
jeden fall sehr geil dieses thema vor
allem dieser fluss der hier wirklich die
ganze zeit her geht und dann ja noch
seinen kleinen kriegen hat hier kann man
sich bestimmt ein paar coole sachen
hinbauen wie immer wenn ihr irgendwelche
ideen hab was man hier bauen könnte
könnte jetzt einfach boni als video
antwort senden ich werde an dem wenn
school ist habe ich beim letzten sieht
ja auch so gemacht und dann würde ich
einfach sei
wenn es euch gefallen und boarder hinten
das sieht echt cool aus ich mag das wenn
das so alles auf wasserhöhe ist wie
immer wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
gebt dem video einfach einen daumen hoch
das zeigt mir dass im juli views haben
wollte betrachtet werden mehr kommen und
hier kommen auch mehr wenn ihr wieder
mehr wollt dann gibt einfach einen
daumen hoch und schreibt mir die
kommentare eventuell weitere sieht die
ihr kennt die allerdings die breite
öffentlichkeit nicht kennen die ich dann
mal vorstellen soll
und dann würde ich einfach sagen ich
gehe jetzt erstmal schön nach draußen
denn bei mir scheint die sonne das ist
sehr sehr komisch aber es ist halt so
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
tschüss